[Música]
llegamos al momento de hablar de los
titulares de la prensa internacional con
rosa pérez masdéu en revista de prensa
rosa bienvenida muy buen día vamos a
hablar entonces de los poderes no santos
de la ultraderecha en américa latina
como también lo estábamos avanzando
antes de comenzar en forma nuestro
programa rosa buenos días raúl feliz
miércoles exacto empezamos por esta
amplia investigación que ha sido
compuesta por distintos medios de aquí
de la región latinoamericana y que
analiza la fuerza y las estrategias de
la extrema derecha en sus respectivos
países no pero con rasgos en común como
son por ejemplo las alianzas
internacionales con organizaciones de
eeuu vinculadas por ejemplo al tramp
ismo o con organizaciones europeas como
la española box por otro lado otro rasgo
en común también es la
instrumentalización de esta crisis
sanitaria y económica de este miedo y de
esta incertidumbre y una alta presencia
en las redes sociales y bien vamos a
comentar los temas que han tratado los
distintos medios de cada país aunque no
podremos centrar muy a fondo animamos a
toda nuestra audiencia a que entren e
indaguen en estos análisis porque son
realmente increíbles muy interesantes
empezamos con ojo público perú que es el
medio que ha coordinado la investigación
que dice alianzas en el congreso contra
la agenda de derechos de la mujer en
perú por otro lado la silla vacía de
colombia comenta las estrategias
camufladas de colectivos anti aborto en
colombia y recordemos que esto en una
semana que va a ser crucial en este
aspecto porque la corte constitucional
va a tener que fallar sobre la
despenalización o no del aborto
por otro lado pop-up de méxico dice
fallos judiciales que impulsan los
derechos de las mujeres radicalizan la
extrema derecha en mexico bien a raúl
vemos como los derechos de las mujeres
son un target un objetivo para la
extrema derecha sobre todo la más
vinculada con el ultraconservadurismo y
en otros temas el diario de red de
argentina comenta mi militancia mi
territorio y mucha prédica virtual
estrategias de la derecha para ser la
tercera fuerza en la ciudad esto en
relación a las legislativas del domingo
pasado en argentina donde la fuerza la
libertad avanza quedó en tercera
posición en buenos aires y por último el
tema de agencia pública de brasil
médicos y grupos antiaborto promueven
tratamientos ineficaces contra lakovic
en racing así es rosa vamos ahora
entonces con cnn la administración vayan
sopesa cómo abordar los juegos olímpicos
de invierno esto en beijing la capital
china exacto hemos elegido las tienen
porque es uno de los medios que ha
participado en poner este tema en la
agenda mediática que se ha hecho eco de
hecho de una columna de opinión
publicada en el washington post una
columna de georges drogan un analista
político que es citar de acuerdo con
distintas fuentes familiares con los
planes se espera que la casa blanca
anuncie anuncie quien el presidente de
byd en ni ningún funcionario del
gobierno estadounidense asistirá a los
juegos de beijing este boicot
diplomático dicen las fuentes tiene por
objetivo responder a las violaciones de
derechos humanos por parte del gobierno
de china sin en los deportistas
estadounidenses eso sí el analista
aclara en su columna que a pesar de que
asegura que sus fuentes son de dentro de
la administración estadounidense ni la
casa blanca ni tampoco el departamento
de estado ha querido declarar
oficialmente para esta columna así es
rosa vamos a jugar con él al jazira el
club nuclear mundial estado en este
artículo rosal es una infografía muy
ilustrativa que nos ayuda a comprender
cómo se reparten no las potencias
nucleares del mundo vemos en esta
primera imagen los 32 países que
producen energía nuclear y por otro
lugar los 9 países que tienen armas
nucleares y en medio los 7 países que
tienen ambas cosas china francia india
pakistán rusia reino unido y eeuu y
dentro del artículo encontramos otros
gráficos también como por ejemplo en la
que medida la electricidad de estos
países proviene de la energía nuclear
con francia a la cabeza con más de un 70
por ciento de su producción
basada en la energía nuclear o por otro
lado también el número de misiles
nucleares que tiene cada país y vemos
que entre rusia y eeuu poseen el 90 por
ciento de los misiles nucleares del
mundo y para allá vamos rosa para
utilizar la energía nuclear con toda
esta crisis energética y climática en el
mundo ahora vamos con the gardian no
culpo a los clientes por enfadarse quien
dice esta frase esta es una entrevista
realizada a un propietario de distintas
cafeterías en birmingham en reino unido-
que asegura que no tiene problemas para
encontrar clientes y akon a la crisis
sanitaria más o menos controlada con la
vacunación pero que sí que tiene muchos
problemas para encontrar trabajadores y
es que según las cifras las cifras del
gobierno británico cerca del 30 por
ciento de los negocios de hostelería del
país tienen problemas para encontrar
personal y tal y como cita el
propietario de estas cafeterías antes de
la pandemia y del break sit el 90 por
ciento es 2 su plantilla eran jóvenes de
la unión europea y recordemos raúl
también como suele pasar la escasez de
personal una plantilla ajustada suele
repercutir también en los derechos
laborales de los trabajadores pues rosas
gracias por toda la información nos
vemos mañana jueves con más la revista
de prensa ahora pasamos a hablar con
nuestro primer invitado el día
[Música]